good morning john so you know how covet
19 is a disease that is caused by sars
cov2 which is a virus it feels like it
would be better and simpler if we just
called that the covid19 virus right so
why don't we just do that well in the
early 1900s doctors started noticing
something weird about some different
diseases they would sometimes have
patients with shingles a really specific
disease where you get a very painful
rash on just one side of your body but
then later those patients children would
often come down with a totally different
disease chickenpox which is like lots of
different itchy bumps all over the body
so they started to think that those two
diseases might be caused by the same
pathogen and they started to look for
evidence of that after a lot of work in
the 1950s it was finally confirmed
separately in two different ways by two
different scientists thomas huckleweller
and evelyn nicole so this is one reason
why we don't name viruses after the
disease they cause indeed it looks like
sarco v2 might kind of cause more than
one disease there's covid19 and then
there's like a blurry line between that
and long coven if you want to know more
about long covered we did an amazing
scishow video about it i'll put a link
in the doobly-doo the varicella zoster
virus though which causes both shingles
and chickenpox is a very clear-cut case
children get chickenpox when they are
infected by the varicella zoster virus
and that happens either through droplets
in the air or through exposure to the
fluid from the rash or the bumps or more
rarely they can get it from exposure to
a person with the shingles rash which
also contains the virus then almost all
of the time quite quickly the child's
immune system will fight off the disease
and that virus will take refuge in your
body for the rest of your life it finds
a place to hide and that place is at the
base of nerves near your spine and then
as you get older your immune system
might get weakened by stress or by
medication or just by getting older and
it will kind of forget about the herpes
zoster virus and that will allow it to
spring forth and infect the nerve at
first that causes like tingling and then
itching and then pain as the nerves get
inflamed and this is why shingles almost
always happens just on one side of the
body in a specific area because it's the
individual nerve that is having the
infection the severity of the pain and
discomfort from shingles which i can now
personally attest to because i'm getting
over a case right now feeling much
better but it was very very bad it
doesn't hurt anymore it just itches it's
one of the reasons why we vaccinate
almost all children against chickenpox
in the u.s now this means far fewer kids
are getting chickenpox and in the future
they will be much less likely to get
shingles as adults because you don't
catch shingles shingles is in effect
people might be mad at me for saying
this like long chickenpox but other
places that aren't the us are not
vaccinating kids against chickenpox and
the reason why is wild and may include
my individual case of shingles in the
u.s 95 of adults have had chickenpox
which means that they could get shingles
but only around one in three of them
will but in 1995 we started to vaccinate
pretty much every kid against chickenpox
and cases of chickenpox among kids of
course plummeted and that meant that
younger people like me were less likely
to be exposed to the virus from sick
kids that exposure would be like a kind
of natural vaccine that would work best
for people in their 30s and 40s those
people have fairly good immune systems
they're also more likely to be around
sick kids that would normally remind our
immune systems to keep up the fight
without those reminders the immune
system is more likely to let the virus
already in our bodies start to replicate
and shingles slips through those cracks
and that's especially the case when
combined with immune suppressant
medication and stress of which i have
both so in effect i may have gotten
shingles so that my son doesn't have to
shingles rates kind of have to go up
before they can go down rates of
shingles and young people like me have
indeed been on the rise though it
doesn't seem to be affecting the rates
of shingles in older people where it is
more dangerous and that's also helped
along by the fact that we now have a
very effective shingles vaccine in
addition to the separate chickenpox
vaccine right now you can only get it if
you're over 50 because it's in short
supply but my guess is it will be
available to younger people eventually
this is just another example of how
complicated disease and epidemiology and
public health are it's just all
complicated and hard to figure out and
so i'm very grateful to all the people
who are working to figure it out right
now and to the people who have worked to
figure it out in the past including
evelyn nicole who was in her twenties
when she first isolated the varicella
zoster virus and who died of
complications from covet 19 in 2020.
john i'll see you on tuesday